السياسه والاقتصاد عنصراني متلازمان
ويؤثران على بعضهم البعض هذا الامر لن
يكون بمن انا عن الانتخابات النصفيه في
الولايات المتحده
هنا نيفادا احدى ولايات الجنوب الغربيه
واشهر مدنها لاس فيغاس المعروفه بعاصمه
المتعه والترفيه في العالم والتي تعتبر
مصدر دخل اساسيا للمواطنين كما تعتمد
نيفادا ايضا على قطاع التعدين وصناعه
الالات وقطع غيار المحركات
عام 2020 ضرب فيروس كورونا العالم وكانت
نيفادا اكبر المتاثرين حيث اصبحت لاس
فيغاس الصاخبه صامته لترتفع بها معدلات
البطاله الى رقم قياسي لاكثر من 34% في
اكتوبر من العميدته وما ان بدات في التحسن
حتى ضرب التضخم الولايات المتحده والعالم
فتاثرت الصناعه وبات شبح الركود على
الابواب واصبحت تمتلك معدل تضخم هو الاعلى
في البلاد
كل هذه العوامل جعلت الانتخابات النصفيه
في ولايه نيفادا تشهد منافسه شرسه على
مقعد مجلس الشيوخ حيث يتمتع الجمهوري
والمدعي العام السابق ادم لاكزالت بفراس
الفوز على كسر كورتيز ماستو اولي لاتينيه
تحصل على مقعد في مجلس الشيوخ عام 2016
ووفقا للاستطلاعات راي اجرتها صحيفه
واشنطن بوست القى الناخبون باللوم على
الديمقراطيين لسوء الاوضاع الاقتصاديه اما
في السباق على منصب الحاكم يتنافس الحاكم
الحالي ستيف سيسولاك اول حاكم ديمقراطي
لنيفادا منذ 20 عاما ضد الجمهوري جول
مباركه عمده مقاطعه كلارك
عقد من الزمن لم يستطع الجمهوريون الفوز
بمقعد في مجلس الشيوخ في نيفادا لكن
الازمات الاقتصاديه قد تقلب المعادله في
الانتخابات المقبله